what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know normally we would cover like a
DC video today but I just discovered
that there are Fight Club comics like
fight Fight Club comics that basically
follow up to the original film now ah
spoilers these comics are going to have
spoilers for those who haven't seen
Fight Club and me I don't know anybody
who hasn't seen it or those who haven't
seen Fight Club here's my question if
you haven't seen Fight Club why it's
like one of the best movies of 1999 like
dude okay David Fincher has made all
kinds of cool movies he made like like
World War Z and he made seven he did
alien three but we'll sweep that under
the rug he made all kinds of amazing
movies like over the years Fight Club is
probably the best it's new Fight Club oh
my god Tyler Durden Tyler Durden man
it's one of the coolest thing I love
that scene where Marla says that when he
calls her up asking like who's Tyler
like Who am I what's my name she's like
Tyler Durden it was like I was like oh
my god dude it was like one of the
coolest reveals ever in the history of
movies
that's why Fight Club is so popular yeah
that's why it's so cool because movies
just amazing but it's like one of the
best reveals ever and if you were
looking at if you knew what you were
looking for then you could pick up
almost right off the bat what was
actually going on especially when Brad
Pitt first shows up so uh picking up
with Fight Club - now here's the thing
this takes place ten years after the
original Fight Club and it was kind of
interesting because Chuck Palahniuk was
the one who wrote this story and he's
actually the one who wrote the original
novel back in 1996 but one of the things
that goes on is in the original Fight
Club
in the movie the kedward of the
character of Edward Norton is never
named you never actually know the name
of his character he just referred to as
the narrator and in the book is the
exact same way but what this does is it
kind of adjust that and it says that
this guy now goes by the name of
Sebastian and that's probably done just
for the purpose of being able to write
the story because in reality trying to
translate the original Fight Club theme
to a comic book would seem kind of
difficult to do like it would seem
wildly difficult to difference so what
this does again picking up ten years
after the life of Tyler Durden is
actually pretty mundane it's pretty
boring here and the reason why is
because he's kind of moved on to a life
outside of everything and he's left his
whole life he left the whole army behind
right like Project Mayhem he left all
that stuff behind that's all basically
gone here and so from this point it's a
matter of him just trying to cope with
his life and what we end up finding out
is he's basically just been taking like
a series of pills in order to keep from
going crazy now the other indication
here is that he has a younger son there
is a girl here she looks more akin to a
babysitter than anything else but he
does have a younger son and this is kind
of the crazy thing the younger son is
showing something akin to the
similarities
Tyler Durden had when I guess that
Sebastian had when he was Tyler Durden
god this is getting a little Banias
already the reason why I say that is if
you remember back to the film which is a
little bit more on the film's themes in
this in this comic but if you remember
back to the film you ended up having
this scenario where Tyler Durden was
expressed you know Edward Norton's
character is basically you know
exploring with different things like
light like creating nitroglycerin
different things like that
and he was going through and creating
like these devices that could be used so
like causes much destruction and and
literally mayhem as humanly possible his
son is doing the same thing but the
difference here is that his son doesn't
seem to have split personalities instead
his son is doing it because he's just
curious and that's the question is who
was it that taught him how to do that
and we're not immediately given the
answer to the question the reason why is
because what Sebastian's been doing has
been popping pills to suppress the Tyler
Durden personality and this has been
going on for ten years and so there's no
indication that Tyler Durden is actually
back instead like he's essentially out
of the picture now and so then it
becomes a question of passive Ashton
broken himself and is he the one
teaching his son to do all these things
so it gets kind of nuts because from
here it switches over to the character
of Marla singer now Marla was
interesting in the first Fight Club
because as most of you guys remember her
in Tyler met at one of those one of
those self-help groups like ever which
one it was they met at but the whole
idea behind Edward Norton's character
was ID suffered from insomnia and the
only way he could relieve his insomnia
was going to like these self-help groups
and receiving like you know basis not
really adoration so much as like
sympathy and the result was that it
became somewhat of a drug to him now
eventually he encountered Marla at one
of those organizations and he
immediately spotted her as being a being
a false personaly she wasn't she didn't
suffer from any of the things that she
claimed she did and so for her it was
more of like an addiction kind of a
thing it was they were both suffering
from like major issues and so what they
did is they kind of paired up of course
she gave him her number and they agreed
to kind of state so like switch groups
they would never go to the same group
they would always go to their own
alternate routes and as screwed up as it
was it was actually kind of cool and so
the two of them basically went forward
and essentially kind of started well not
really started a romance or more there
are more like acquaintances than
anything else kind of like an on-again
off-again friendship if there is such a
thing for her she ends up going to one
of these groups where it's basically
individuals who suffer from a progeria
syndrome those individuals who have have
an illness where their genes are kind of
screwed up they can't bond with the
right proteins and what this means is
that they have accelerated aging but
they're they're mentally young and so
like for example one of them says that
they're nine years old another one said
where is Lee
next month the other one says they're 11
years old Marlys shows up here and says
well I'm suffering from like a mild
version this is the thing about her
character it's kind of the way she is
not only that it works exceedingly well
and I would expect nothing less the guy
who what the original book is a guy
who's writing this comic and so you
can't really argue that it's not it's
not the way the character supposed to be
because I mean you know it's his
character you know but but still the
thing about Marla is she's very
devil-may-care she puts off this air
that like she doesn't really care about
anything that like nothing really
matters to her at all when in reality
there's a lot of things that matter to
her but it's almost kind of like a
defense mechanism it's one of those
things you kind of have to go see the
movie in order to really understand what
her characters like but the problem with
this is that as she's going through
she's really just kind of venting about
her husband about Sebastian I said we
saying that like he's a weakling now
compared to the man that she used to
know and the reason why is because
eventually in the film she basically
starts sleeping with Sebastian's other
personality with Tyler Durden and the
result is that she falls in love with
that version of Edward Norton's
character and so that means that like
that's all she really no she doesn't
know like the other side the more
toned-down side the more relaxed side
the side that's trying to figure himself
out that's very insecure and there's
very very weak you know emotionally and
physically or at least it seems that way
and so she falls in love with his darker
half now eventually she realizes what's
going on once you get to like the end
scene and all that could all that
different stuff she kind of understands
what's taking place and that's why the
two of them have kind of come together
but for her she does not like the
version of her husband that pops pills
and gets rid of the Tyler Durden side
she wants the darker side of her husband
back
the darker personality and so it gets
kind of cool because all she does is sit
around complaining about it well what he
does is he actually goes through and
starts going through all her searches
looking at all the group's she's
supposed to be at and figures out which
one she's at and so when he goes to the
lobby with the intention of you know
presenting her with flowers and wishing
you a happy anniversary
he interrupts her while she's basically
talking bad about him while she's
tearing him down and talking about how
much of a weakling he is and so on and
so forth and rightfully he feels
betrayed and this really kind of like
crushes him emotionally now the other
thing about this is it really kind of
references back to the bar scene now the
bar scene from Fight Club is like one of
the coolest scenes ever because that's
really where Fight Club starts you end
up having having Tyler Durden scared I
think it's how hundreds character who
said punch me as hard as you know I'm
sorry was Edward Norton I think he said
punch me as hard as you can something
like that anyway one of them instigates
a fight with the other and they kind of
break into a fight with each other well
as they go back to the bar and they
constantly get in these fights it
attracts a crowd and that in turn leads
to going in the basement of the bar and
starting the Fight Club and so
it's it's really really cool because
like that's where it all started when
she kind of has these flashbacks to word
you know to what her husband used to be
now ultimately you end up finding out
that Edward Norton was fighting himself
but still like it's it's a it's a cool
moment but she really kind of looks at
the darker side of her husband who was
kind of out there because that's what
you learned about Edward Norton's
character the character of Brad Pitt was
basically like he literally told him I'm
everything you wish you could be like
I'm the guy who does what he wants when
he wants how he wants and doesn't really
care about anybody else I'm carefree I
do whatever makes me happy and for the
character of Edward Norton he was weak
but he was emotionally and physically
weak and so we didn't really have what
it took for that side of himself and so
we you know you end up having you know
Tyler Durden new kind of took over and
it's kind of a cool thing because when
he gets home his wife really kind of
treats him like crap and he ends up of
course you know driving off and and so
on and going to a bar this is one of the
cool things because when he goes there
he ends up you know intending to buy a
drink and the guy says well your money's
no good here now again this is an
important moment and the reason why is
because when sebastian goes to pay he
has this mark on his hand and the guy
hands his money back with the same mark
on his hand now that was kind of like a
calling son that was a way to show that
you were part of the Fight Club and that
went back to when Brad Pitt went when
Tyler Durden yo and when Brad Pitt and I
guess Sebastian for the sake of the
story when they took up residence in the
dilapidated house and he ended up
creating lye and then pouring it on his
hand and then just sort of you know sat
there and gave himself like this this
gross scar on his him it was designed to
kind of say like this is your measure of
being able to endure pain this is you
being reborn and it was a mark of saying
like you have transitioned from the
person you used to be to the new person
that you are now and so it's kind of
like you know again kind of a sigil
saying like you've officially joined
Project Mayhem and so this guy is part
of their ranks it's basically Chuck
Palahniuk sway of telling us like in
this story that that Project Mayhem is
alive and well because it was never
truly eliminated like Project Mayhem was
never like defeated it's not like all
the members of Project Mayhem were
killed at the end of Fight Club they
were still out there the other part of
this we end up learning about Marla is
that what she's been doing has actually
been like changing the pills of her of
Sebastian of her husband's character
she's been switching his pills up
instead of him taking the pills he's
supposed to be taking with the
medication inside instead it's been
things like sugar or aspirin is
basically been placebos which means that
as far as we can tell the character of
Tyler Durden is not gone he's basically
just kind of waiting to make his return
and it's kind of a cool moment here
because what ends up happening is you
end up having like you know Sebastian
going through and mowing the lawn and
kind of going crazy when like the dogs
barking and carrying on
and then of course that night you know
it's really just kind of like well
that's the neighbors that's you know the
neighbor's dog and he keeps throwing his
dog poop over the fence and things like
that it's these small little things that
go on they kind of begin to like bring
back the character of Tyler Durden
because for the first Sebastian in the
original Fight Club he was like the
passion he was like uh he was in the
passenger seat of his own life and so he
didn't really have any control of
anything he was just kind of along for
the ride his life was out of control and
so Tyler Durden kind of took it back in
control and this is what this does is it
presents a scenario and simply saying
that like everything's going the same
direction all of this has happened
before
and all of it will happen again if you
believe Battlestar Galactica
but it's kind of a cool thing here
because it's just sort of setting the
stage for Tyler Durden to come back the
medicine he's taking isn't working
because it's not actually medicine and
the circumstances of his life are
pushing him closer and closer to the
edge and so in this moment what he does
is he says basically fine I'm gonna go
talk to the neighbor like I'm gonna go
talk to coffee and we're gonna get this
all sorted out and then he shows back up
at home with like a black eye now of
course this turns into Marla like
approaching him and trying to you know
initiate intercourse between the two of
them which she does but it's not
actually Sebastian she's sleeping with
and we can tell that simply from the art
that she's basically sleeping with Tyler
Durden his dark personality so that
means like that side of himself is
coming out now of course this also shows
the insomnia of Sebastian is coming back
in again and so it's again setting the
stage for the return of Tyler and all
these things going back to the way they
were before and so what happens is you
have Sebastian who goes to a hit and
test goes to a therapist for one of his
daily sessions and when he's hypnotized
he's basically thrown into the backseat
again and then when the Hitler says
snaps Tyler Durden emerges and so that's
when we end up finding out that in all
these times of his life much like in the
original Fight Club where Edward Norton
thought he was sleeping and it was
actually Tyler Durden just running
around and doing things that's exactly
what's happening right now it's
basically this scenario where you end up
having like Tyler Durden who's basically
been running the show the entire time
but he's been literally orchestrating
all these events setting all these
things in motion continuing the efforts
of Project Mayhem and actually expanding
it to a global scale it was already on
its way there in the original Fight Club
but now like it's full-on in that level
and it's really cool and it's really
really awesome to see because you end up
having like Sebastian wakes up and he's
got Tyler Durden sitting over him and
that's kind of the funny thing here it's
a bit of a dance on the wild side and
kind of been in your imagination a bit
because Chuck Palahniuk almost presents
this idea that like Tyler Durden is a
wholly different character and it makes
sense because in the original Fight Club
Edward nor
was hallucinating his other personality
his other personality had a physical
form in so far that only Edward Norton
could see him but it was a way to
interact with his own personality and so
that's kind of what's happening here is
that this is there really is no tyler
durden here there's no guy with a blond
hair it's just it's it's sebastian
hallucinating at all and and imagining
it all in his own head but believing all
of it is real and so when he and marla
wake up a fire has been set inside the
home and that's when you really kind of
have to draw the conclusion that
sebastian was the one who said it i said
where you end up having marla and you
end up having sebastian hubail out of
the house they end up realizing that
their sons still in there and so when
tyler goes to reach for the door it
burns him there's no real way for him to
get in and the result is that the entire
house just starts burning down around
him with his son trapped inside but with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
two comments explain make sure you guys
at the sub button to become part of the
robb core guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and yeah
god I love Fight Club I'll catch you all
later peace
you